how do you go about figuring out your
values sometimes you can literally just
grab a piece of paper separate into
little boxes and you might have boxes
for family life or lifelong learning or
health or creativity so you can kind of
fill those boxes with the different
aspects of your life and then in each
box kind of ask yourself what kind of
person do I want to be in this area of
my life so maybe it's family
relationships what kind of sun do I want
to be to my mum what do I want to
represent to those people how would that
show up in terms of behavior and action
you know daily behavior and you just
kind of fill it with with words or
bullet points and that gives you this
picture of what life would be like if
you were living in line with all of
those values and sometimes they pull on
each other so sometimes they conflict
you know you might have this real idea
of being a successful entrepreneur but
actually that sucks all of your time and
you also want to be a family guy and you
want to spend time with your kids often
there's this Balancing Act where okay
life has pulled me in One Direction and
I want to pull it back this way so it's
not about setting goals and doing them
perfectly it's about always just tipping
the balance